e
e e
good morning yall it's uh if Miss uh
Newman if I can get you to close that
back door thank you very much
uh welcome to the first orientation
meeting of the public works and
highways um I'm representative David
Mills uh this is let me check with
representative Jack is this our sixth or
seventh this is our starting our seventh
term together here all on Public Works
Um this can to be rather loose
orientation I'm going to try and get
everybody out of here by 11:00 there's
no reason we're not going to do any
heavy lifting or anything
um I'm going to rely a lot on the older
members to correct not to correct but to
add add into things that they think the
new members of this committee need to
know and that's basically what we're
going to just doing today um we've we've
got three bills so far you should I'm
sorry we got four but they've they've
only got three that's been printed out
you should have them all um we'll be
addressing those in a week or
two we are going to have to share this
room with Health and Human
Services uh so our letter drawers our
mailboxes I call them uh don't get used
to having those in in six months we're
going to have to completely vacate this
building and we're going to go somewhere
else and we probably won't have drawers
we probably won't have an assigned room
it's it's going to be chaos after that
so we're going to try and get everything
that we possibly can done out of here by
June uh having said that uh I want to go
around the room and have everybody
introduce themselves and give us a
little background on who you are and and
what you've done and I'm going to start
at the far end with representative
Newman
please yes good morning gentlemen and
it's nice to see you all again and I'm
so happy that another colleague of mine
has has joined the this organization um
I've been on this committee since I was
first elected to the state house that
was in
2016 I didn't know what it was like what
it was going to be like but
representative Jack had given me a heads
up on what we do and um he was spoton
with it um lived in nashwa since
1981 was on the school board in Nash
for eight years that's why my hair is
white um I've worked at the polls in
nasua and um been involved with pto's
the schools volunteer programs and uh
and now this thank
you represent representative holie
please hello
you're on
now
my I don't know this is my fifth
term I think it's my fourth term on this
committee I was in the military I'm a
disabled vet I was an intelligence
analyst in the Air
Force I've also owned a construction
company I designed and built over a 100
commercial industrial buildings
and some
roads and then I started a business so I
for 30 years I operated a business I
owned five
stores uh I have a
good construction
background and that's primarily why I'm
on this
committee thank
you thank you uh representative rockmore
is is it rockmore
please good morning I'm Ellen rockmore
I'm from Hanover I teach expository
writing at Dartmouth College um my
experience with budgets is primarily as
a board member um of various nonprofit
organizations and I'm happy to be here
thank
you thank you uh representative vone it
might be running a little bit late I
don't know he normally lets us know
representative Lewis is excused he had a
prior commitment today let's move down
to representative
Brown thank you good morning everybody
uh my name is representative Richard
Brown currently uh representing Carol
County District 8 uh represent or
current Senator MC's old seat um I was
in Carol County District 3 uh the prior
term and I was on H Municipal and County
government I am a retired civil engineer
actually used to work with
representative Edgar at seab Brook
station for about three years and uh had
a great time working with him I'm also
retired corporate engineering manager
for United Parcel Service where I was in
charge of project management and
environmental engineering for them
worldwide so um I'm happy to be here on
this committee thank
you thank you representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chairman yeah my
name's Mike Edgar um I represent Hampton
and uh retired um Navy captain and
professional engineer worked places all
over um I was really glad to get on this
committee I had at that time I had the
fight to get on it when I first got on
and so I've been on this will be this
will be my fifth term there I came in
originally went to a different committee
for for one year I came in in a special
election uh I think one of the great
things about our committee is is is the
way we work together and I really
appreciate that and really looking
forward to seeing that continue and it's
great that we work on the capital budget
and the 10-year Highway plan there is
really really really good projects to
work on besides everything else thank
you thank you uh representative cluder
okay thank you Mr chairman uh
representative John cluder representing
Claremont and Cen uh I am in my now in
my 17th term I happen to be the ranking
member on this committee but I have
served as chair Vice chair and Clerk of
this Committee in my service and I've
served all but one term of my 17 terms
in this committee the only time I wasn't
on this committee is the then Democratic
leader asked me to go to another
committee for various reasons uh but the
one thing I learned I really appreciate
this committee after my two-year absence
and the Committees I served were okay
but they weren't like public works and
highways where you can get some stuff
done and and most of the time we're very
bipartisan thank
you thank you representative Boyd please
my clerk Mr chairman thank you um
welcome everybody back uh my name is
Bill Boyd representing Hillsboro 12 the
town of meramac uh my background is I
served locally in my community for 10 to
15 years at the planning board level at
the Town Council level and at the school
budget committee level and and economic
development um
um like who was the special was it you
with the special was it Mike with the
special special election who Who first
got special yeah so Mike and I have
something to Comm we both got elected in
a special and uh when I got elected in
the special my my dad gu rest of Soul
suggested that I try to get on public
works and highways because he always
liked the idea of being able to create
and and build this country because he
was a lance of and he did a lot of work
on Public Works projects during during
his younger younger days so I'm on
public works and highways and um I Echo
previous comments that were made we do a
lot of good work we work together we're
collegial we're collaborative and um
it's an honor and a privilege to be your
clerk as well so um thank you very much
and uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Boyd representative milin
my vice
chairman uh my name is uh representative
Melvin I've been this is my fourth term
my second term on this committee um and
fortunately I got chosen as Vice chair I
spent 30 years on my planner board I
spent 15 years on my zba six years a
member of the board of Selectmen and I'm
really happy to be
here thank you thank you representative
bogert good morning my name's
Representative Steven bogert I'm bellnap
County District 5 uh this is my second
term as a state rep and second term on
uh Public Works I'm happy to be on
Public Works uh I have been uh chosen to
be the assistant majority whip uh for
the Republican side and I'm also the uh
whip for the
committee um I've worked 30 years with
Motorola over seeing uh manufacturing
operations uh daytoday for two-way radio
communications for fire police and
military uh I've also have 30 years of
zoning and planning under my belt uh I'm
also a city counselor for the City of
Laconia and I currently also serve on
three different boards uh all nonprofit
so my income from that is as equal to
the income from being EST State Rep
which isn't much so uh with that I'd
like to thank
you representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman uh as the chair mentioned is my
seventh ter I'm starting my seventh term
all all of it on this committee uh there
was a term when I was Clerk of this
committee and I've filled in as clerk a
few times when there's been absences uh
I have an engineer in background uh it's
in computers but it is very helpful uh
to have that so I look forward to
serving on the committee another
term representative B thank you um uh
Ralph B hillbo District 38 which the
towns of Hudson and litfield this is my
ninth term two two terms in election law
six terms in
education I'm a retired software
engineer I've been a selectman budget
committee and school board and I'm
currently uh on the national Regional
Planning Commission which I thought
would be a good time to come here thank
you thank you representative jurus
please good morning everyone Lou jurus
and I represent uh Nashville's Ward 7
and this is uh my second term here and
second term here on the committee uh my
background is an engineering electrical
engineering and I worked on some FEMA
projects with a um a contractor from
Washington DC from Mobile Radio vans in
the early days and then I spent uh about
25 years at the tea down in Boston where
uh my my emphasis was a lot on the
two-way radio system there the UHF
Communication System uh running fiber
optic cables in the um in in all four
lines of the tunnels also working on
commuter rail uh some of those systems
as well uh I worked on the original
Charlie Card the the original uh Charlie
C system that came out about 14 or 15
years ago various infrastructure
projects in the tunnels uh days and
nights uh and and really all around the
the all around the city including uh the
uh third habit tunnel well slightly on
third Hotel project but also on the big
dig project doing some coordinations
there I'm a landlord I've got uh two
daughters College age actually one of
them's a nurse now and uh I've done some
work with at the polls as well in nsha
and it's good to be with you all it was
good to work with you last term as well
and good to know everybody here thank
you thank you uh representative sudor is
not here we'll move down to
representative
kazinski uh my name is Tom kazinski I
represent District Five in Rochester uh
it's my Fifth Fifth term in the house
and my third term on this committee
um I'm in the poultry business I'm a
large live poultry dealer we Supply the
uh largest wholesaler in New York City
52 weeks a year and um locally uh I was
involved with the tax cap in Rochester
I'm one of the five original sponsors of
the tax and spending cap and I was
highly involved with the the new zoning
in Rochester ended about 10 years ago
thank
you representative fauler thank you I'm
Barry fauler uh represent Swansea en
Richmond that's s 10 it's my fifth term
all on this
committee I am a semi-retired land use
attorney although I've been doing mostly
estate and uh and Trust work
recently uh before this gig I spent 30
years managing Transportation Planning
projects for various state and local uh
Highway Transit agencies and the federal
government it's been a lot of time
working with the
MBTA uh
I formerly a
board member of the uh adok Regional
School Board got 20 years of land use
board experience and about 10 or 12
years of as a election Precinct
Warden well thank you and and welcome to
all our new members um couple of
things I just want to bring up we have a
couple of members absent let's let's get
that straightened out right away if
you're not going to be here send me an
email
and copy in both my vice chair and the
clerk and if you're a member of the
other party uh
please copy in representative cluder so
he's aware of that um that takes care of
absences another thing we're going to
ask you to because I know some people
are rather personal about this is
between now and the next next time we
meet we're going to I'm going to ask our
clerk representative Boyd to get
everybody's um working emails if you
don't want your email to go to your
legislative email uh just so that we can
get a hold of you in case of some kind
of short notice emergency you know we do
hb25 here which has got a lot of heavy
lifting and a lot of short notices to
get that capital budget done and
including with that um your emails any
any phone numbers so that we can contact
you we won't abuse it we won't send it
out uh it's it's worked very well over
the years for privately working with
this
committee uh and has been mentioned a
number of times this is probably the
most nonpartisan Committee in this
entire L Office Building um we pride
ourselves in most of our bills I would
guess 90% of our bills go on the consent
calendar out of the 10% that don't go on
the consent calendar I would guess 8% of
those 10% is because it's got a a fiscal
note and it can't go on the consent
calendar so we like to work out all our
problems the best part about this is we
are just committed to this state's
infrastructure it's roads it's Bridges
it's highways it's buildings it's if you
can build it we supervise it and we
build it we build it we fix it and um
our great partner in doing all that is
the do and I'm going to ask them to
speak here in a couple of minutes
uh I just want to make sure I want to go
around the room again not oneon-one but
I just want to invite any of the older
members that have been here to to uh
recap anything I might have missed one
other thing and I'm going to point it
out right now not to point to anybody
but representative water is permitted in
the committee but keep it under the
table
please and I can tell we're mostly of a
certain age that we don't have to worry
about laptops Tik Tock any of that
stuff but the clerk just if you know if
the clerk is allowed to have a laptop if
he feels it's necessary but he looks
like yeah he's of a certain age too I'm
old school Mr chairman okay and then I
just want to I want to call on a ranking
member representative cluder to start
with anything that I've missed please
okay just to let you know representative
alone did email said he he was going to
be absent because he and his wife had to
get some visas or something they're
going to take a trip later on so I'm
sorry he didn't notify you but I'll try
to make sure he notifies you as well
next time okay thank you anybody else
any of our uh
multi multi-year members want to bring
up anything that I may have missed
before we turn this over to
do representative pulner I just want to
say appreciate the the comments I I
think the best thing about this
committee is that we talk things through
people don't understand something or
disagree we try to work it out
uh that's I think the best way to
approach everything I wish every
committee could do that but we're uh
we've got a tremendous history of U
working together I really appreciate
that I thank you for that comment I also
want to point out
that with representative fer and his
English skills one time we we were up
here for about a 20 to 30 minute
Amendment once on on the apostrophes and
the and the semicolons on where
something should be in a bill we've long
since found out that we don't have to do
that
anymore but that's the way we work
together in this committee
representative Newman please yes thank
you I
just on the first go around that I
didn't mention but earlier when I was in
here and I spoke to representative
fidelia and representative Jack over the
holiday time we had an opportunity to
travel
to South Florida and to Asheville North
Carolina I saw the results of tornadoes
that hit the Port St Lucy area um after
the Hurricanes the
existing um compromising of trees and
traffic signs that are still all bent uh
sheet metal and trees and then in
Asheville the continued rebuilding of
their infrastructure it gave me a huge
um perspective on how important do
infrastructure roads Bridges and these
were things that could not have been
prevented but people were working around
the clock to keep things moving and
rebuilt thank
you seeing nobody else then at that
point in time I think we'll invite like
I said our biggest Partners the dot up
David rodrig please
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is David rodrig I'm
the assistant commissioner and chief
engineer for the Department of
Transportation um commissioner Cass had
a conflict he's going to join us just as
as quick as he can um with
me is Steve you want to introduce
yourself said oh
okay good morning I'm Steve leonti I am
taking over for Kathy M hampson um just
a little bit of background I spent 10
years with the Attorney General's office
uh um working in what was known at the
time TR uh the transportation and
construction Bureau which represented do
and the department of safety I've spent
the last seven years at the department
as the administrator of the Bureau of
right of way and with um Kathy's
retirement I saw this as a good
opportunity and something I was
interested
in I I just have one question for Mr
lante are you still going to be on on my
Capital overview committee or is
somebody being replaced
there I think Steve will be on on your
Capital overview committee yes just want
to make sure we got all all the good
players yes absolutely back to you Mr R
and Shelley would you introduce
yourself I'll just say yeah good morning
I'm Shelley Winters I'm the director of
the division of Aeronautics Rail and
Transit I've been with the department
for over 24 years and in my current role
for about two years so thank
you excuse me Mr chairman yes not mine I
just wanted uh a question a compliment
uh I just wanted to to Mr Lebon the
legislative liais on and I think he's
available not just to us but all
legislators right if they have a
question with
the okay and I want to compliment when
I've asked him for help either for
myself constituents or other legislators
you've always been very responsive and I
appreciate it I uh you've got some big
fills of shoe with Kathy M hamson but so
far you're filling those shoes thank you
and thank you representative and and let
me start by by saying the Department of
Transportation truly benefits from this
committee we see you as our champions in
the legislature we know you hold us
accountable and and help to guide us but
as you started your committee meeting
and talked about working together in
that Collegiate attitude we certainly
benefit from that and we want to support
you in that so today I'm to give a brief
presentation and overview of the
Department of Transportation but I want
you all to know we are available to you
anytime we pride ourselves on on that
availability and we want to um answer
any questions you have at any time and
in the end that helps you to advocate
for and support us and we appreciate
that so starting with the the
presentation the first slide gives you a
high level view of our our o
organizational structure there are three
Commissioners commissioner Cass myself
assistant commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner Andre Brier we have five
directors that oversee different parts
of of the department Shelly is the
director of Aeronautics Rail and Transit
we have a director of project
development a director of operations a
Director of Finance and a director of
policy and
administration we also have two offices
that report directly to the
Commissioners the first is our office of
safety if you will that is a group
that's dedicated towards roadway safety
and making sure that we're focused on
making the roads as safe as possible the
other is our asset
management um asset performance and
strategy office and they really help
make sure that we are focused on the
performance of your transportation
system of our roads and bridges and
making sure that we continue to track
our operations maintenance and
replacement of that transportation
system to drive the lowest life cycle
cost of our roads and and bridges we
then have a series of um bureaus that
report to each of those divisions as
well our mission at the Department of
Transportation is transportation
excellence and in our purpose we talk
about some of the things that are
important from our perspective with
transportation and transportation
Excellence we want to support Economic
Development and we want to make sure we
provide a a wellmaintained efficient and
reliable transportation system for all
Road users and it's very easy for us to
focus on roads and bridges in New
Hampshire but we have the department of
transportation we have Rail lines that
we're responsible for as well and manag
we have bus services that we pass
through federal funds to to help support
to help people get around in New
Hampshire we have the airports that we
manage as
well some key facts about the do we have
1651 permanent positions where a
significant sized agency but we'll talk
about a little bit in the future how
that number has come down over the years
not not increased we also want to
highlight that currently we have 404
vacancies or
24% of our Workforce and that's
impacting how well we can we can meet
our mission of Transportation Excellence
we have
2160 State Bridges of which 115 are on
the Red List we have 168 Municipal
bridges of which
23 are on the red list all of our
bridges are inspected every two years
unless they're on the Red List in which
case they get inspected more
frequently um some other key facts we
have about 4600 centaline miles of of
roadway we target Paving 500 C miles per
year we maintain over 100,000 signs 96
million ft of striping 442 traffic
signals um 11 public trans transit
systems 25 publicly accessible airports
194 active state-owned Rail lines and
some others in that in that table from a
funding
perspective um in fiscal year 2024 our
actual expenditures were $72
million we like to to show in the in the
chart below that of that
702 56% of it or almost 400 million of
it goes to Municipal Aid and
construction directly to our
construction projects that the
department advertises and oversees the
construction of it 44% of those funds
come to our operating which is um
maintenance and operations uh Personnel
cost winter maintenance um and so
forth diving in a little deeper to
Aeronautics Rail and transit for
Aeronautics we have 25 open to the
public airports in federal fiscal year
23 we granted over $20 million
to those 12 federally funded
airports um we have 13 airports that do
not receive federal aid and in calendar
year
204 551 th000 in revenues was generated
from the aviation registration fees on
the rail side six Active operator
agreements with four Freight Rail lines
and two tourist Excursion Rail lines we
have about 150 mil of actively used
State home railroad 290 Mi of abandoned
or inactive state-owned Rail and 230
mies of privately owned Rail lines from
a public transit perspective we support
11 local public transit systems inner
city bus and commuter Services Boston
Express and Community Transportation
the administration of our department is
made up of the executive office I
described a little as as we started um
we do charge some some of our budgetary
activities to Administration and the ex
executive office including our go Bond
Debt Service transfers to other agencies
retiree health and so forth um also in
the executive office we have a public
information person and we work on our
management strategy as well in
administration we also have finance that
helps us with the the budget contract
management running our our federal
program although we get a a significant
amount of federal funds those funds come
in very specific buckets and we have to
manage what those federal funds get
spent on we don't have full discretion
to put those funds wherever we want we
have to meet the federal funding formula
so we spend some time with that in
financing in policy in administration we
have human resources internal audit our
occupational health and safety section
um focused on the health and safety of
our internal dot Employees Federal
compliance and hearings and
legislation our division of project
development that's our group that plans
engineers and supports um the right of
way and our construction program that's
a group that builds our 10-year plan
that you all will will see we'll talk
about that that that schedule coming in
a in a minute in fiscal year 2024 our
project development section add 84 new
construction contracts and provided
construction oversight of 85 existing
active construction projects those
construction projects totaled a combined
value of $800
million also last fiscal year we
advertised um
$331 Million worth of of new
projects on the maintenance and
operations side um we have a bureau of
Highway Maintenance and that's broken up
into six districts Statewide we have 86
different Patrol
sections um or I'm sorry 84 separate
Patrol sections we maintain 4600 ceni
miles of roadway this is the the group
that does our um winter operations that
does our our summer work plan that we
administer um ourselves that responds to
emergencies um tries to keep up with our
guard rail maintenance drainage
maintenance Mowing and and everything
else I always like to point out 84
Patrol sections it sounds like a lot but
the reason we're successful with our
winter maintenance program it's because
of our Logistics because we're set up
and 84 sections really leaves one
section for about every three town
cities or towns in the state so it's
it's not as much when you think of the
geographical area that that we cover
also in our Operations Division we have
our Bureau traffic that's responsible
for roadway line striping we strive to
stripe our roads every year the paint
that we use um wears off with the snow
plows in the winter and the traffic in
the summer so we strive to restripe our
road roads every year they take care of
signs um traffic signals and they also
manage our speed limits we have a bureau
of bridge maintenance that maintains our
state
Bridges um our Mechanical Services
Bureau that takes care of our Fleet our
Fleet exceeds uh a th000 units the the
value of our Fleet exceeds a hundred
million and this is a group that takes
care of that and manages that Fleet we
have a fuel distribution section that
maintains 87 fuel sites Statewide that
not just the Department transportation
uses but communities can use some
nonprofits can use as well and that fuel
management system serves as a strategic
Reserve in case ever anything ever were
to interrupt the the flow of fuel we
could keep our trucks rolling and
provide fuel for for state police and
others we also have a transportation
systems management and operation Bureau
that manages the traffic on the road
through our intelligent transportation
system a little bit uh about the the
highway fund and how we're funded we
explain it that the highway fund is not
the dot and the do is not the highway
fund which basically means all of the
money that's generated from
the what we call the road toll or the
fuel tax registrations and so forth that
doesn't all come to do a portion of that
goes to Department of Safety a portion
of that goes to the communities and the
small portion of that goes to some other
agencies as as
well we also use the the highway fund uh
federal funds a federal program flows
through the Highway F fund as as well um
the state highway fund the non-federal
portion is a primary source of our
funding
budget um and in
57.1% of the highway fund was
appropriated to do um almost 30% to
other agencies and 133% to
municipalities we also have our Turnpike
system and we're very fortunate
New Hampshire to have that that Turnpike
system the turnpike system operates as
an Enterprise fund which means the money
generated in the turnpike system has to
stay in the turnpike system so when we
talk about financial challenges it's not
like we can raise the tolls and spend
that money anywhere we want to around
the state the the turnpike system
self-supported but the money raised
there has to stay there and there's some
facts and figures uh about the size of
that system in your
presentation um finally we get to some
issues and and challenges that we have
and the commissioner Cass stated it very
well in his budget presentation this
year when he said we are accomplishing
what we need to um but we're not able to
do all the things that we think we
should be doing um and a little bit of
of the reason why um was one is
inflation and what I can tell you about
our construction cost we talk about two
things with construction costs we talk
about inflation but we also talk about
escalation so since we've come come out
of the covid-19 pandemic we continue to
see rapid
escalation of construction costs that
that are not accounted with in a regular
as high as
3.7% inflation that we try to put put on
our projects to keep up with things and
what we're seeing now is that also takes
on a regional characteristic uh around
the state there are parts of the states
where bids are coming in very close to
to what our estimates are in other parts
of the state where the bids may be 40%
greater than than what our estimates are
and that's largely driven by Workforce
the contractor's ability to to um hire
folks to to keep folks and also duration
of projects and more complex projects
get more expensive than than we think
they they should
be um a little bit more um on a
vacancies again I mentioned
24% we are focused on what we call
Recruitment and Retention but we still
have a difficult time attracting and
retaining
employees um we Al also have a difficult
time with some of our winter maintenance
contract rental providers winter
maintenance we we do uh about half do
people in trucks and about half rented
contractor people in trucks and as time
goes on it's getting more and more
difficult to attract those th that
contract rental agreement um with a
truck and Driver this is not something a
big roadway contractors want to do this
is something more the the
backyard um contractors and there used
to be a lot of farmers would do with
their equipment and people in the winter
and they just they're they're not there
like they
they used to
be um so from a productivity perspective
because of these challenges we do fall
short on some of our our targets that
we'd like to achieve we're prioritizing
resources to the most critical areas um
but we are reducing some of our
preventative maintenance and that
preventative maintenance is is the best
way to drive the lowest life cycle cost
for our roads and and bridges and all
our assets so issues and challenges um
we do include a a chart that shows our
reduction in in positions over the years
so that everybody knows we have worked
to to become leaner as we've adopted
technology better equipment to help us
get our jobs done we have already shed
the positions that that those
efficiencies brought to us we also
include a line on there that shows
vehicle miles traveled so that's the
total number of of miles that people
have traveled on New Hampshire roads and
that continues to to climb despite our
our fewer
people some of our longer term
challenges include funding insufficient
Highway fund revenues to fund current
levels of service lack of matching funds
for federally funded projects limited
State funds for non-federal Aid um
eligible roads declining toll
revenues um or road toll revenues coming
from vehicles that have better fuel
efficiency and the electric vehicles um
and the highway fund as most on this
this committee know has had a series of
one-time fixes over the years but never
any long long-term structural
fix little bit on the 10-year plan
process that's how we plan our capital
projects for the for the future we
update our 10year plan every two years
um we that's a continuous cycle and
where we're at with that this April
we'll be starting the the public portion
of our update of the plan we'll
incorporate some some recommendations
from the Reg planning commissions we'll
then work with what we call gaset which
is uh the governor and and um executive
council's advisory Transportation group
um we will get the 10-year plan right
for the for the for our executive
counselors we will go out last time we
had 24 25 public meetings to get
feedback on that plan we'll finalize the
plan with the executive counselors
present it to the governor make any
changes that the governor wants and then
it will come to the house through your
committee and then it will go to the
Senate and finally back to the the
governor for
Signature hopefully not this spring but
the next
spring we also want to highlight the New
Hampshire Transportation Council this
Council was established by New Hampshire
legislature in
2018 it's intended to partner with the
do and the the general court and this
can be a great place that if you want to
have things studied or looked at
carefully you could consider referring
that to the transportation Council and
with that I thank you for your attention
and Mr chair of your pleasure I'd be
happy to take any questions now but I
also do want to continue to keep the
door open for the future and make sure
folks know um we're always here to
answer your
questions thank you um one thing I
wanted to make sure everybody understood
is although the uh the 10-year plan is
always always ongoing for
doot they'll do all the heavy lifting
all the heavy work and they'll pass it
over to us next by any not next by any
the second half of this year correct so
for our the first half of this year we
will be concentrating on the capital
budget
hp25 but you're going to keep hearing
about the 10-year plan over and over and
over again I've already had at least
three people from various Towns come up
to me and ask and you'll you'll be
hearing it also ask if they can get this
on the plan ask if they can move this up
you know things like that and there's a
procedure for all of this so just go
ahead and ask when you have to uh aside
from that uh
I have nothing else do we have any
questions yes we certainly do
representative bone thank you Mr
chairman the question I mean we have the
same problem in town
getting plow operators it used to be
that was the majority of our plows now
it's not what do you see is the problem
there what do we see is uh is is as is
the problem and and you know if I give
you an honest answer it's a living wage
we need a living wage everything cost of
everything has has gone up these are are
tend to be some of our lower paid paid
workers um and there's competition for
for that and we we need a a living
wage representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman on the long-term funding
challenges I'd like to highlight the
work of the road toll commission uh
which is a commission that is charged
with develop in a long-term plan to
solve the funding challenges and the
next meeting of that is scheduled a week
from
today that is true do we have any other
questions for the dot at this point in
time representative jurus thank you Mr
chairman uh back to uh the you know
plowing plowing and wi the
maintenance so are we and been hearing
about this uh you know in the med you
know here and there in the media
especially the past few months uh any
incentives that do is offering for
contract and these are contracts correct
these are these are contracts that you
engage in with uh uh a PL a comp like a
landscape company or a big trucking
company or is it not it's not by the
hour per se is it so it's it's it's both
first we we struggle with our own
internal Workforce and making sure we
have a seat and in every plow truck and
we do have incentives to help make sure
of that to to help incentivize people
who have CDL licenses but work other
places in New Hampshire do and other
state agencies to to come to work with
us for the winter and it also
incentivizes our current Workforce to
stay with us through the winter so
that's a a $5,000 bonus for folks who
work with us through the the winter
season and thanks to that bonus we have
about 140 to 145 winter volunteers who
help us out who make up for the 198 or
so vacancies that that we have um it's
important to understand that that's also
a 25 247 job we can't fill one shift
never mind multiple shifts so those
people are available when just when we
need them to plow snow but for the
duration of the storm for our rented
equipment we have not not this past year
but we have in the past increased the
the cost or not the cost but increase
our hourly rate for those contract
rented trucks with operator and we also
have a system where we pay a 10hour
minimum at every two weeks for um 10
payments during the winter season that's
to make sure that these these folks have
the money to to register Ure and get
their equipment ready but in in addition
to that 10hour minimum they're paid the
actual hours they work and it is an
hourly
rate thank
you any further questions
seeing none we're just about ready to
wrap this up I think uh if there's
nothing else further the the do wants to
contribute at this time I'd just like to
ask you to please stay a couple of
minutes I got a couple of personal
things I've got to talk to you about um
I don't know when we're going to
schedule our next meeting
yet what what I do know is that we will
be scheduling almost all of our meetings
on
Tuesdays Wednesdays will definitely be
out Wednesdays are Comm committed to uh
HHS Thursdays uh chairman McDonald and
myself have agreed that depends on who
has the heavy lifting to do that week
when we have hb25 to start working on
we'll be using on some Thursdays uh but
I'm going to try and keep most of our
normal scheduling to Tuesdays having
said that next Tuesday is already off
the calendar as representative Jack said
because we've got the road toll
commission meeting here and I opt not
to have a backtack meeting where we
would come in at noon and the road to
start at 10 o'clock so um just pay
attention to your calendars
representative
your and uh that'll be when we schedule
our next
meeting if there's nothing else Welles
so you right now it sounds like if I'm
following you correctly that probably
our next meeting will probably public
hearings will be on Tuesday January
28th at the
ear probably the 28th Tuesdays and maybe
Thursdays once we get in the capital
budget butre that's the plan okay good
that'll be helpful as far as our
schedules are concerned none of I'm I'm
stay away from the we we were meeting
Fridays for a while because of the
double room commit but that's off the
table I'm going to try and keep all of
our businesses on Tuesdays Thursdays one
necessary we can count on that if yes
representative
bogur thank you Mr chairman
um we do have sessions on Thursdays that
was stated that they're going to keep
our sessions on Thursdays so that would
intermit with that or okay thank
you okay
the only thing is announcement I'd like
to see the Democratic members over in
the members Lounge for a brief CAU as I
need to discuss some stuff with our from
our leadership uh we should be done it's
up uh on the first floor just above the
cafeteria if you want to bring some
lunch something to eat I'm probably
going to get a cup of coffee and it
probably be in about 1015 minutes from
now okay thank you we'll be out of there
probably by
11:30 e